[Music]
good morning
I'm Chuck vest president of MIT and it's
my pleasure to welcome all of you to
this remarkable session at a series of
dinners I host every year in the
president's house here on campus I tell
each and every one of em I tease
graduating seniors that their goal
should be to leave the world a little
better place for their having been here
I know it sounds trite and terribly
old-fashioned to them but the fact is in
the life of Henry Kendall lies proof
positive that that is the right goal and
that indeed it can be accomplished for
as we stand here at the threshold of a
new millennium the world indeed is a
better place for Henry's having been
here and we would all be even better off
if he were still here to help us wrestle
with our challenges our plans for a
better future and our efforts to educate
tomorrow's leaders in fact Henry Kendall
was exactly the kind of leader that we
will be needing more than ever an
exceptionally talented scientist who
never accepted limits on the scope and
variety of his professional interests
revered and effective teacher the
dedicated and outspoken advocate for
policies having planetary reach and
profound consequences for the global
community he sought to serve he remains
a model for our faculty the model for
our students we were very fortunate that
his legacy remains central part of the
MIT tradition this is a tradition or a
spirit that embraces an appreciation for
non-traditional thinking flexibility to
support new and unproven ideas the
interdependence
respect for the interdependence and
cross fertilization among disciplines
sense of public service on national and
global scales a commitment to diversity
and our programs and in our people and
the fierce dedication to excellence in
all that we do Henry
literally embodied each and every one of
these qualities and more very shortly
before his death I had a very common
experience I got sucked in by the fog at
Logan Airport but it turned out this
time it was a great good fortune because
Henry Kendall was also there both of us
missing by two hours their intended
flight and it was a wonderful
opportunity to spend two hours simply
talking with Henry about his
exceptionally wide range of interests
and as all of you know as true of every
conversation with him it was truly an
education his understanding of the world
ranged from subatomic physics issues of
the technologies of war and peace from
environmental protection and public
health to photography and underwater
exploration there's an indication of
Henry's own influence in so many domains
but so many distinguished people have
come here to MIT today to take part in
this tribute to his life and work on
behalf of the Institute I am proud to
welcome all of you to this program Henry
Kendall set the highest possible goals
for himself his students his colleagues
in the global community he helped to
build and that he strove so hard to not
only preserve but to improve and
focusing on the larger issues about
which he cared so much we do more than
serve his memory we also serve our own
best interests more importantly the
interests of our precious fragile and
beautiful planetary
welcome to Cambridge thank you all for
joining us today and now I would like to
ask the head of our physics department
mark castor to come forward mark
thanks Chuck
first of all welcome to all of you on
behalf of the physics department in
which Henry was a faculty member and the
laboratory for nuclear sciences of which
he was a very proud member in which he
did his research
I want to thank Curt Godfrey and Jerry
Friedman and Francis Lowe for organizing
what I think we will find to be a
fascinating and interesting day and
Isabel Cunha vasconcelos who did a lot
of the hard work to make this happen in
physics we love heroes and Henry was a
hero he was a hero of our department it
was a hero of the laboratory for nuclear
sciences he was a hero of the Union of
Concerned Scientists he was a hero of
many others who admired him without any
formal connection in physics of course
our heroes are the people who break new
ground who are pioneers who discover
things we didn't know and make us think
about things in ways we hadn't thought
about them before and Henry certainly
did that
Henry was passionate about many many
things and I think what we're really
going to see today are the array of the
things that he was passionate about he
certainly was passionate about physics
and he was passionate about issues of
society I think I'd like to say a word
or two about things he was passionate
about what you may not know so much
about Henry was passionate about
education especially hands on education
for many years he taught the freshman
laboratory course imagine what it was
like to be a freshman arriving at MIT
and to go into your first mechanics
course and told you or have you
to have a lab and then you arrive at the
lab and here is a Nobel Prize winner to
explain to you how things work was
amazing experience for these kids
Henry was was passionate about young
people and about giving graduate
students and junior faculty a chance to
pioneer the way he pioneered he was
passionate about many things and he
didn't hesitate to tell his department
head when he thought the department head
was doing the wrong thing or one of his
passions was involved and I learned an
awful lot from him because of that I'm
not going to say anymore he always will
be one of our heroes and I think at the
end of the day today you don't already
you'll see why so let me now turn the
program over to Adelle Simmons who's the
vice chair of the Union
many thanks to Chuck and to mark for
co-hosting this event with UCS I'd like
to welcome all of you here I am the vice
chairman of UCS a position which I took
on following Henry's death because I
believe so strongly in the importance of
what UCS does and wanted to ensure and
work to ensure that it remains a strong
and powerful voice for issues we care
about UCS was founded at MIT in 1969 and
for those of you who don't know it is a
research policy and advocacy
organization that works on issues that
can only be understood if you get the
science right the current focus is on
arms control and the environment and
within the environment particularly
climate change and issues relating to
agriculture Henry was the chairman of
the Union of Concerned Scientists for 26
years every board meeting was for me a
seminar a seminar I always felt that was
especially designed to help me as a
college president and then a foundation
president as I tried to lead the
organizations I was running Henry always
had ideas he always pushed us to be
bolder to be more courageous to be more
outspoken his leadership in those
meetings was truly extraordinary and for
as the big ideas I remember as much as
the wonderful stories about his last
climb the Nobel Prize dinner or his
latest dinner in Hollywood during this
time Henry worked very hard to expand
the constituency for the issues he cared
about and six years ago as climate the
climate change issue was beginning to
attract public attention and the
Endangered Species Act was under threat
the Pew trusts established the national
religious partnership to bring religious
organizations into the environmental
movement pew asked the Union of
Concerned Scientists to serve as its
science advisor one part of the national
religious partnership program was an 11
minute video which were showing today it
may seem a little dated but it's the
last film with Henry on it it is a
reminder of his willingness to Anne
gage diverse audiences and build unusual
partnerships for the causes he believed
in and it is a reminder that Henry was
always ready to use the media other than
the written word or in addition to the
written word and as far as I'm concerned
the concept of James or old Jones as God
is a pretty good one thank you we're
going to show the video right now
[Applause]
in the beginning when God created the
heavens in the earth was a formless void
and darkness covered the face of the
deep then God said let there be light
and there was light
and God saw that the light was good and
God separated the light from the
darkness God called the light day and
the darkness
all the life that we have ever known is
contained in a thin layer that wraps
around the surface of the earth its
mysteries challenge human comprehension
research to understand them and their DB
speeding is at the heart of both science
and religion
some call this the creation some call
this the biosphere no matter what their
perspective all beholders vision
and God said that the waters bring forth
swarms of living creatures
and that birds fly above the earth
across the Dome of the sky
we relate to God through God's handiwork
nature is God's textbook it's God's gift
to existence so to read God and we read
nature
[Music]
so God created the great sea monsters
and every living creature than the moons
of every kind
and every winged bird of every kind
and God said that it was good
and God made the wild animals of the
earth of every time and the cattle of
every kind and everything that creeps up
on the ground of every time and God saw
that it was good the creation but
something to be deeply valued precious
for all of us and I like to say that it
doesn't matter how you view the origin
of the creation you come to the same
conclusion
diversity of life that surrounds us it's
a gift it's something that was
bequeathed to us and it's something that
we bequeath back down on to our
descendants
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome next
if we have the steak
let's have the bush
when the cathedral first announced that
there would be a procession of animals
to the altar for blessing
there was a great deal of uncertainty
skepticism curiosity and now as to how
it would be received but when we opened
the great two-ton bronze doors of the
Cathedral
there were 4,000 silent people in this
great sacred space
[Music]
and we watched an elephant and a camel
an alarm
Eagle a-ha
and as they all move down to nave the
length of two football fields people
wept
[Music]
and as nearly as I could understand
people were experiencing a moment of
reconciliation
[Music]
the challenge is for churches and
synagogues to open their doors more
fully to life itself invite life in the
wonder of life the reverence of life it
doesn't have to be an elephant or a
llama coming down the nave to the altar
it just can be a sense that what's out
there now belongs in here inside our
congregations and inside our hearts
[Music]
so God created humankind male and female
God created them
and God blessed them and said to them be
fruitful and multiply and fill the earth
and subdue it and have dominion over the
fish of the sea and over the birds of
the air and over every living thing that
moves upon the earth human beings are
clearly distinct in creation a strange
combination of the dust of the earth and
the breath of God we have a god-given
creativity which we can use to improve
the world and improve our lives and at
the same time that creativity which is
our God likeness is constantly
restricted by our creatureliness if you
will the idea that even though we're
unique in creation there are absolute
limits on human behavior and our choices
of how we use God's world
the human species where do we fit in the
great diversity of life that surrounds
us for thousands of years the concept of
Dominion has been an important theme in
religious thought the scriptural view is
Dominion does not mean abusive use it
means earth keeping it means create
creature keeping if we decide to take
charge which we have as human beings on
earth then we as good stewards of the
creation are obligated not to destroy
that over which we have been given
Dominion
so this Dominion really is service it's
the same sort of thing that's reflected
in Genesis 2:15 Adam is asked to serve
the garden and the Lord God planted the
garden in Eden in the east and the Lord
God took the man and put him into the
garden of you to serve it and to keep it
Adam has asked to serve the garden
that's a really interesting concept
because what comes out of that is that
recognition that the garden or the
creation more broadly serves us serves
all their creatures with with the fruits
of creation but we also serve it and so
there's a kind of con service or a
Conservancy or a conservation the
command is a basic command it's the
first command you know to keep the
garden and to care for it and I think
that we have to understand that I mean
it's its elemental I mean that's there
in Genesis before you get the Ten
Commandments caring for the creation is
a fundamental call of the Lord places
upon us all our relationship to the
earth is also a subject of profound
interest to scientists
[Music]
humanity we were created here we evolved
here this is our home to which we are
adapted in exquisite detail that means
that the levels of oxygen that we
breathe the humidity the temperature all
things maintained in equilibrium it's a
pretty steady state by all these
millions of organisms in the midst of
which we live is exactly what our bodies
need in other words we have a superb
environment beautifully adapted to us
now we should be attempting to conserve
it for our own good
[Music]
as we better understand how the
biosphere protects us we are realizing
that instead of protecting it we have
been altering it at an ever-accelerating
pates
this is the first time in the history of
people on earth that we are having a
tremendous impact on the entire
biosphere of the earth we're beginning
to appreciate the magnitude of that
influence never before have we had as
many people on earth never before has
the use of the resources the biological
resources of the planet been as great as
it is now and the impact that we are
having is absolutely astounding and
frankly quite frightening
[Music]
we could lose as many as 20% of the
species of plants and animals on earth
particularly on the land surface where
most of the damage is occurring right
now in the next 30 years or so if we
don't take stronger measures the only
way to save the rest of those life is
through the preservation of natural
environment habitat reserves
[Music]
what we need is a much broader
recognition of the problems that
careless human activities are bringing
upon us a realization that we can not be
rescued by science and technology
because these problems at their root are
human problems and have to be dealt with
it has such and it's clear to the
scientific community that this is the
case thanks to our scientific
understandings we know now what we
didn't know before we know the damage
we're causing and we know the
consequences of our actions and I think
that changes the situation greatly in
terms of the ethical nature of the
dilemmas we're facing we really have to
save the creation and we have to save
the planet and we can only do that if we
feel that it is a unitary plan a unitary
goal that we all have something at stake
here I think we have to look deeper in
our hearts if you like this is a problem
with values it's not a problem of
techniques or approaches or science it's
a question of values it's a moral and
ethical problem challenge as to how we
this living generation treats the
environment that we so critically depend
on I think that this issue more than any
other issue has the potential to
overcome race class gender whatever
divisions that are you know playing in
our society that we can come together on
this I think the articulation of the
environmental crisis has made me think a
lot more deeply about what is the
biblical vision humanity's position in
the world
and in the cosmos and I think that the
biblical material has a great deal to
say on the subject
[Music]
and God said to Noah make yourself an
ark for behold I will bring the flood of
waters upon the earth you shall bring
two of every sort into the ark to keep
them alive for the first endangered
species act is where Noah is asked by
the Creator to take two of every kind
and preserve their lineages and it's
interesting that the cost of this
Endangered Species Act is immense Noah
spends perhaps something like a hundred
years immense resources very valuable
would a great deal of time and then
perhaps the most devastating of all - to
most of us would be the derision that
one would get if one would spend a
hundred years building a very large boat
on absolutely dry land but the result is
that he is the one who was faithful in
preserving the species in preserving
their line and the rest of the people
perish from the earth
[Music]
and God said to Noah this is the sign of
the Covenant which I make between me you
and every living creature
I so set my bow in the cloud and it
shall be for a sign of the Covenant
between me and the earth the covenant is
with all life with every creature and of
course what this means is that as we
look at the rainbow what we're supposed
to do according to biblical teaching is
to remember that every species all the
things that have been preserved from
that deluge in the past are worthy of
our effort of preservation today the
covenant that we hold is a covenant that
sorry
for the whole of creation human and
non-human and that in this present
crisis it reminds us and holds us
accountable to that kind of
responsibility for all god is me
[Music]
in a certain sense we conduct a
continuing conversation with God as we
move through God's creation in the
natural world if that's true somehow
every act which destroys a species
circumscribes our conversation with our
Creator the destruction of a species of
God's creation is metaphorically like
tearing a page out of Scripture
[Music]
when you're looking at the planet from
outer space you see lights at night you
see clusters of lights in the large
cities the planet isn't dark from outer
space it is dotted with lights well that
is the human presence how many lights
can the planet tolerate is a question
that runs through my mind if we succeed
in lighting up the planet at night where
we have done good for the earth or will
we have destroyed it thus the heavens
and the earth were finished so God
blessed the seventh day and hallowed it
because on it God rested from all the
work done in creation
you know rather than working and
changing and creating unceasingly the
Sabbath teaches us to say enough it
teaches us to stop creating and changing
and doing but you really appreciate and
sanctify the world as it is another
aspect of the Sabbath is that the land
has a Sabbath of its own
when you enter the land I'm going to
give you the land itself must observe a
Sabbath to the Lord in the seventh year
there shall be a Sabbath of solemn rest
for the band one of the things we are
asked to do in the scriptures is not
relentlessly press creation that is done
through the teaching of the Sabbath the
Sabbath not only for human beings but
also the Sabbath for the land if we
relentlessly press the land then what we
do is to interfere with the capacity of
the land to restore and rejuvenate
itself if we do that we begin to erode
the very home upon which human life
depends
as human pressure on the natural world
increases scientists warned about the
long-term effects
I think that it's very difficult to know
where the limits are oftentimes you
don't know it until it's too late I
think that we as humanity need to do
something different than just say to
scientists help us understand where the
limits are which is appropriate but I
think that it's also a social issue in a
social and moral question that involves
how we view this world that we're using
and what the limits are
[Music]
if we're really honest about our own
lives we have not only violated the
Sabbath for the earth but we also have
violated the Sabbath for ourselves
we have gotten on what we call the
treadmill the rat race we spend a lot of
time racing around and there's a
necessary first step and that is we have
to scale back in some of our frenzied
activity to the point where we can
reflect on who we are why we're here and
where we're going
if our descendants come to realize that
in a couple of generations we have
destroyed a large part of the creation
by carelessly extinguishing species and
allowing species to grow extinct they
are going to consider us a ship of fools
they're going to consider us as being
one of the most destructive generations
of all time in terms of what matters the
most of them I think there's a growing
movement that is accepting this moral
responsibility and saying things aren't
right this is not the way it's supposed
to be what do we do about it and that's
where I see a partnership between
science and religion serving a very
powerful very very important role we are
called to be stewards of the earth and
that is part of my faith commitment is
part of my faith journey but this must
be an important part of that I must take
it very seriously
there as we are called to keep the
garden that we understand that and that
I pass that around that it's not just
becomes part of my faith journey that I
become a missionary for the planet there
are many levels on which this these set
of challenges is great the thicket of
difficulties has to be met on the
individual level where people realize
and accept changes not necessarily
damaging changes but just more careful
use of resources recycling supporting
others in recycling and so forth but
also at a larger national international
level
there has to be support for changes in
the way government's approach these
problems
[Music]
and the support starts at the grassroots
the most important thing in stewardship
really is that we be able to make our
institutions work to be stewards we
can't just think of ourselves in this
society as just individual actors our
action is always through institutions
and by and large is to institutions that
will make a new future I think we need
to remember that everything is a piece
of a puzzle including us and it's not
ours to pull apart there's a prayer that
I love that we say every Sabbath and
says that even if our own mouths were as
full of song as the sea and our lips is
full of praise as the breaths of the
heaven and our eyes as bright as the Sun
in our hands is outstretched as the
Eagles of the sky and our fetus Swift as
gazelles we could not thank you enough
and I think there's an important lesson
in that in some way all of creation
praises God and in every voice in that
chorus is needed
[Music]
both science and religion call upon us
to keep the earth all of our voices
permeated
[Music]
the lights - for the room I think some
of you may not remember that one of the
important outcomes of this partnership
with the religious community was the
Endangered Species Act which was renewed
shortly after the Gingrich Congress was
elected and I'm not sure how many you
remember the news clips of the
demonstrators from the religious
partnership outside of Congress which
was a powerful part of ensuring the
renewal of the Endangered Species Act
you all have Tim Wirth's biography in
your program he's the current head of
the United Nations Foundation he served
as a member of Congress for 18 years
including six years in the Senate and
was Under Secretary of State for Global
Affairs between 1993 and 1997 a new
position created by the administration
I've known Tim for years and what
distinguishes him are his values and the
energy and passion with which he pursues
the issues that he cares about and in
this Tim and Henry were much alike
Tim cares about energy population
climate the environment and he wants to
get results and he does get results
within the US government he shaped the
United States position heading into the
Cairo a UN conference on population
there is no question and I should say
one thing I remember going to Baltimore
with him - we were both speaking at a
Pugwash conference but there he talked
about his last trip to Baltimore which
was to meet with the Catholic leadership
in the city so he too was reaching out
to new constituencies but the result of
Cairo has really shifted the way in
which all of us think and work towards
dealing with the important population
issues without the u.s. leadership and
without Tim's leadership the US would
not Cairo would not have happened the
way it did and the u.s. would not have
had the position that it did and Tim did
the same thing around the Kyoto
agreements he really worked very hard
within the government and also with
those of us who
were outside the government advocacy
groups to develop an agenda for Kyoto
that was as strong and as powerful and
as based in science as possible Tim knew
Henry very well and he's going to both
reflect on his own experiences with
Henry and provide a framework for the
next series of panels which will be
addressing several of the critical
issues of the next decade issues that
were very much a part of Henry's for
most concerns Tim
[Applause]
well thank you very much Adele it's a
great pleasure for me to be here with
you this morning even if the reason for
the gathering makes the displeasure
somewhat bittersweet the untimely death
of Henry has deprived us of a great and
graceful warrior in this struggle for a
better world but we can take credit and
create comfort in knowing that Henry
Kendall's life will long be remembered
for he was the kind of man that
Shakespeare had in mind when he penned
the words he lives in Fame that died in
virtues cause one of the things I most
admired about my friend Henry he was his
willingness indeed his determination to
get involved to do something about
problems that so many people are merely
content to complain about Henry wanted
science to serve the common man and
woman and he trusted the public's common
sense to produce good decisions if
scientists gave them an honest picture
of reality when I think back on all that
Henry accomplished in the political
arena it's amazing that he found time to
do much science but he was as you all
know as gifted and indefatigable in the
research lab as he was in political
organizing and he was justly recognized
for his enormous contributions when he
shared the Nobel Prize with Jerry
Friedman who's here this morning in 1990
Henry wasn't short one of the premier
citizen scientists of our age he was a
great friend of ours we were planning to
have him on the Grand Canyon this summer
and we had a great trip anyway but
missed Henry tremendously despite my
sadness at his death I'm really honored
to be here to memorialize him today and
one of the best ways I think to do so is
for us to carry on with his work so when
thinking about this this morning I asked
myself what would Henry be doing if he
were here if he were here with us today
I reflected back on the November in 1992
ucs statement a manifesto
laughter by Henry entitled world
scientists warning to humanity signed by
some 1700 to the world's top scientists
UCS warned
warned that quote human beings and the
natural world
are on a collision course alas since
this publication most of these problems
have only gotten worse global warming
for example is no longer a theoretical
danger our best scientists have declared
that there is quote a discernible human
influence on the world's climate and the
consequences are increasingly apparent
forests loss to is accelerating and
scientists recently discovered that the
Amazonian rainforest is being destroyed
twice as fast as previously thought
ominous news considering the current
global rate of loss will leave the
planet with no rain for us at all by the
year 2050 the Geo 2000 report released
last month by the United Nations
Environment Program draws an equally
disturbing conclusion about species loss
25 percent of the world's mammal species
and 11 percent of bird species are at
significant risk of total extinction and
as for water the shortages Henri warned
about in 1992 have now become in UNIP
swards
a full-scale emergency if present trends
continue two out of every three persons
on earth will live in water stressed
conditions by 2025 to be sure there has
been progress thanks to the Montreal
Protocol fewer CFCs are being produced
around the world than in 1992 and a
complete phase-out is scheduled for 2010
yet even this good news is compromised
by the fact that the ozone layer won't
return to normal till at least
2050 likewise with population global
growth rates have fallen significantly
since 1992 humanity is now growing by 77
million a year rather than a hundred
million nevertheless given the most
optimistic foresee at least eight
billion humans on the earth before
population stabilizes around 2050 that's
sobering considering that ecosystems all
red
you're stretched by today's six billion
people there's been some progress as
well in greenhouse gas emissions
DuPont recently startled a skeptical
world by announcing that the company
would reduce its emissions by 65 percent
by the year 2010 65 percent United
Technologies has announced 25 percent BP
and shell or each committed to 10 over a
short period but the administration in
Congress continued to fiddle while the
globe worms in the face of these immense
challenges that may be tempting to throw
up our hands and give up yet here again
I think of Henry and I could almost hear
him heaping scorn on such defeatism did
I mention that another of his signal
traits was tenacity he was after all a
world-class Mountaineer steep challenges
didn't deter him the only spur team on
so succumbing to despair is not an
option for us either
instead in my remaining time this
morning I'd like to suggest some ideas
for addressing our environmental
predicament and more important for
resolving it guided by Henry's spirit I
specifically want to recruit all the
scientists here to join this cause for
our civilization will not overcome these
challenges without the active and
sustained engagement of the scientific
community and that's not flattery
it's fact and I mean the entire
scientific community the challenge is
embedded in the environmental crisis cut
across disciplines and demand an
integrated approach we need help from
physicists like Henry but also from
biologists chemists engineers economists
psychologists and anthropologists your
fellow citizens need you to inform us
with your research inspire us with
visions of a better future and push us
when we act with insufficient boldness
with your help we may still be able to
bring our bring our collective behavior
and our into balance with the natural
systems that make our lives on earth
possible I think that five central
issues demand our immediate attention
weapons of mass destruction population
growth consumption species extinction
and our food supply and a global economy
I'll begin with nuclear weapons because
they represent the greatest and perhaps
the most immediate threat to continued
habitation of the planet dick Carwin
will extend this conversation with much
greater expertise later in the day I
realize of course humanity has made
extraordinary progress against this with
threat in recent years but there's a
long way to go before word out of the
nuclear woods 10,000 nuclear warheads
remain in each of our Arsenal's Russian
and American and many of these are still
poised on hair-trigger status which
makes accidental nuclear war all the
more possible meanwhile Russia's
economic collapse has exacerbated the
problem of keeping nuclear weapons away
from the saddam hussein's of the world
there are 150 tons of plutonium lying
around the former Soviet Union often
poorly guarded in a land where organized
crime makes a mockery of the rule of law
such laxness invites disaster how to
proceed we should begin with the
simplest steps fully fund the expanded
Threat Reduction initiative which pays
for taking apart Russian nuclear weapons
and employs Russian nuclear scientists
in commercial fields so they won't go to
work for Iran in Iraq we should work to
lower the risk of accidental war by
insisting that the Russia and the United
States take their forces off launch on
warning status and making no
first-strike pledges we should begin
shrinking our Arsenal's as close to zero
as possible and the time has come to
formulate and implement a program of
comprehensive nuclear disarmament
including an overhaul of today's
inadequate system for being for bringing
keeping nuclear materials out of the
hands of terrorists rogue states and
criminal bosses this is a complex task
complex set of tasks and it demands as
before the deep engagement of the
scientific community the continuing list
of immediate but no less hazardous storm
clouds and the horizons must next
include population which has to be at
the center of
analysis and activism population growth
95% of which occurs among the world's
poor is not alone the all-powerful
environmental culprit that some people
claim the consumption patterns of the
wealthy are more damaging but the laws
of mathematics cannot be denied even at
low consumption levels more people means
more demand for food water and other
resources not to mention production of
more pollution human ingenuity can
increase the efficiency of our
consumption patterns but technical fixes
can only do so much if we want a
habitable planet in the 21st century
population stabilization is essential
nevertheless most politicians Doug dodge
this issue as do most major
environmental groups because to talk
about population you have to talk about
to the most controversial subjects
around religion and sex our government
used to seriously address population in
the early 1970s then congressman George
Bush chaired the population caucus in
the House of Representatives and was
known affectionately to his colleagues
as rubbers Bush that is true by the time
mr. Bush served in the Reagan White
House and ran for president however he
had changed his tune entirely his
about-face is typical of countless other
good leaders who know better but have
shrunk back in fear of the Catholic
Church and other opponents of abortion
even though those opponents are nowhere
near as numerous or powerful as
politicians think the irony the irony is
the Catholic Church as an institution
has done so much to help disadvantaged
people around the world yet the
unintended result of its population
stance is to counteract that legacy let
me emphasize that in urging attention to
population neither I nor anyone else
seriously engaged with the issue is
proposing to force birth control much
less abortions on on the world's women
quite the contrary
the great breakthrough of the Cairo
Conference on population mentioned by
Adel 1994
was its recognition that women properly
empowered can make decisions for
themselves about the size of their
families and the spacing of their
children and this is the surest route to
lower birth rates when the status of
women is raised by keeping girls in
school instituting legal equality
assuring women access to family planning
and reproductive health care the effects
are unmistakable fertility rates fall
soda child mortality rates because fewer
pregnancies mean healthier pregnancies
and healthier children and the economic
benefits are pervasive the result is to
help break the vicious cycle by which
poverty encourages the high birth rates
that keep people poor to get population
back on policy back on track
we need to reopen the public
conversation on this issue and make our
case with clarity and compassion a
sensible approach to family planning is
both environmentally essential and
crucial to fighting poverty the world
over this public outreach is another
area where we need the scientific
community's help of course calling for
population stabilization can only be
politically credible if reducing
consumption receives equal emphasis my
third point the geo 2000 report calls
for a tenfold reduction in resource
consumption in industrialized countries
in order to free up environmental space
needed by environmental Nations fleeing
poverty I believe that we can achieve
that ton for 10 fold reduction and
without degrading living standards but
this will require strong leadership from
government fundamental reforms of our
economic system major shifts in consumer
and corporate behavior and again
effective and sustained input from the
scientific community the first step is
efficiency not doing without but doing
with less in his new book coal companies
former Assistant Secretary of Energy
Joel ROM documents how such firms is 3m
Xerox and compact are fattening their
bottom lines while sharply reducing
their greenhouse gas emission
simply by improving energy efficiency
another new book natural capitalism
co-authored by a Murray Levin's of the
Rocky Mountain Institute describes
literally hundreds of existing
technologies that increase efficiency
not only in energy but also water
construction transportation and
agriculture indeed virtually all aspects
of our society improving a sufficiency
is essential because it buys us time to
develop alternative technologies and get
them up and running we can do simple
things like regularizing efficiency
standards across the OECD countries and
the helpings highlight the best
practices of leading international
country companies like BP 3m and ABB we
can pull technology in markets as we
once did for computers by requiring the
government's purchase cars only if
they're powered by hybrid electric or
fuel cells we can help close the cost
gap between renewable and coal-fired
power by concerted and consistent
natural national policies and the list
goes on other opportunities will
certainly be found in the unfolding
deregulation of the electricity business
from encouraging consumer choice in the
source of energy to allowing the
demobilization of cost ineffective and
environmentally destructive plants this
efficiency strategy is not new it just
hasn't been tried nor would it be costly
to the taxpayer because we can spend
existing budgets more wisely
the United States government devotes
about 30 billion dollars a year to
subsidizing fossil fuels and nuclear
power but less than 1 billion on
efficiency solar and renewables that
ratio can change another promising
mechanism is the environmental tax shift
whereby government raises taxes on what
it wants to discourage pollution and
resource degradation while lowering
taxes on what we want more of jobs and
investment your colleague at Harvard
professor Dale Jorgenson former chair of
the Economics Department and a professed
conservative has done path-breaking
breathtaking work that shows how such a
tack shift is revenue-neutral sharply
lowers pollution and as an has marked
economic benefits to borrow business
tech terminology the economy is a wholly
owned subsidiary of the environment if
our economic accounting systems were
environmentally honest our society would
now be perilously close to chapter 11
bankruptcy today the market prices for
clean air the market prices clean air
fresh water and other ecosystem services
at or close to zero so people waste them
but if price has reflected true
environmental costs the market could
become a major force for reform we need
help from economists and other social
scientists and recognizing these basic
facts and adjusting our behavior
accordingly but as important as like
economics are if we can forget the basic
biology of all of this we're lost
which brings me to a word I'm only going
to use once this morning biodiversity
probably everyone in this room knows
what this term means but I assure you
that the general public does not so my
plea here is simple would you please
come up with a new lay person friendly
term for what bid for what may be the
single most immediate environmental
threat facing us the public responds
instantly when environmentalists
highlight the threat to warm and fuzzy
creatures like panda bears and sea
otters but people also need to
understand why it matters profoundly
it's the lowly dung beetle and earthworm
disappear as it happens this problem was
one of Henry Kendall's main
preoccupations the final year of his
life he was working with biologists on
how better to communicate to the public
their grave concern about the global
epidemic of species extinctions and I
can think of no better way to honor
Henry's memory than to solve this puzzle
let me now turn to my fifth point food
and globalization how will humanity
feed itself in the 21st century
population momentum will give us at
least eight billion people to feed and
if living standards keep rising those
people will be consuming more food per
capita than humanity does today but the
basic inputs of our food system are
already under enormous stress arable
land is disappearing at frightening
rates soil is eroding about 30 times
faster than its being created and we're
short of water while the global nitrogen
imbalance limits future fertilizer use
yet here again there is ample scope for
efficiency improvements drip irrigation
no telco lavit cultivation and
integrated pest management are all known
tested but in it but inadequately
deployed tools for much more efficient
agriculture many scientists also
advocate another approach to feeding the
world in the 21st century increased
reliance on genetically modified
organisms to raise that resists droughts
and pests and can raise crop yields who
can doubt that the potential of
biotechnology is great the risks however
are also significant for example this
summer when it was widely reported that
corn genetically modified to resist the
corn borer ended up killing monarch
butterflies as well the public reacted
rapidly and alarm bells went off now
maybe that was just bad luck but bio
technology's ability to subvert
ecosystems with unintended effects like
super weeds and new viruses is so
powerful that we as a society should
pursue this technology with only the
utmost deliberation that means at a
minimum that all bio technology
innovations must undergo thorough
long-term testing by the proper
authorities before being released on the
environment it also means that we must
design a better public information
system so the consumers know about and
have faith in what they are ingesting
these issues will surely be debated next
before the World Trade Organization the
WTO is one of the central institutions
of globalization and its upcoming
meeting in Seattle may well be one of
the defining moments in this struggle to
define how global globalization should
operate like biotechnology globalization
has great potential both to help and to
harm genuinely free trade can lower
costs and protect the world for the from
the protectionism that contributed to
the Great Depression sensible
deregulation can do away with unwise
subsidies but globalization does not
deserve support if it does not serve
basic values of our civilization
including respect for democracy equality
and the environment and here's where the
WTO appears to be falling short in
August the WTO ruled that the European
Union must drop an 11 year ban on US
beef treat on US beef treated with
hormones or face sanctions the United
States has also complained to the WTO
about Europe's resistance to genetically
modified food calling that resistance
irrational but why shouldn't the
Europeans be able to question
genetically modified food if we do not
deal openly and rapidly with the issue
of labeling and public information the
backlash to any genetic modification can
become so great as to derail any of the
benefits of the new revolution in
biology and will still have to feed more
than 8 billion people again your help
here is needed and needed now this is
one of the immediate visible and
pressing challenges of globalization the
market has a vital role to play in the
environmental transition but our
governments have to keep the market
environmentally honest we cannot allow
the agendas of commercial interests
alone to trump all other considerations
the truth is everyone can make plenty of
money in the environmental transition if
we just use our heads
in a world where one out of every four
people live on
than a dollar a day an unemployment is
at historically high levels even in
wealthy societies in Europe and Japan
economic revitalization is essential to
environmental progress average people
want to do the right thing
environmentally but no one can be
expected to starve today to save the
environment for tomorrow luckily enough
they don't have to earth Odyssey a new
book by journalist Marc Hertz guard
draws on interviews with top government
and Environment officials around the
world to explain how we could actually
turn a profit by making peace with the
planet following the digital revolution
the next great change will be the global
Green Deal to environmentally to
environmentally retrofit civilization
from top to bottom and trigger another
great economic boom a huge source of
jobs and profits to workers and
companies throughout the world
the profit is limitless says one
Japanese official because the markets
limitless after all we're talking here
about remaking everything from our farms
to our factories our schools houses
offices and everything inside them the
money this could make would give a whole
new meaning to the phrase going green
the opportunity like the challenge is
immense the question facing us is
straightforward enough will we act
quickly and decisively enough to earn
ourselves a longer stay on this
beautiful and bountiful planet to quote
Shakespeare again delays have dangerous
ends but as I recall our friend Henry
Kendall had no patience for delays so
why should we thank you very much
you